[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain un an donc du
scrutin de 2022 la stratégie d' emmanuel
macron de briser en les partis
traditionnels semblent arriver à
maturité mais est ce une assurance pour
lui de gagner même si vous n'êtes pas
madame irma ronces et bien non c'est sûr
les sondages à un an de la
présidentielle c'est toujours un peu
compliqué on se demande où ça peut aller
quels sont les prédictions real mais
clairement se dessine une stratégie
pourrait voler macron très visible après
avoir à s'épiler le gauche le parti
socialiste de l'intérieur en étant ni de
droite ni de gauche
et finalement de droite le voilà qui
attaquent vent debout l air le parti
traditionnel et qui essayent de les
scinder en deux entre son centre qu'il
voudrait dépasser 1 au delà de la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national
clairement il veut mettre en scène un
nouveau duel pour 2022 entre lui et
marine le pen
exactement comme en 2010 est le problème
c'est que sa base est assez étriqués
qu'il aura du mal à aller plus loin et
que marine le pen monte dans les
sondages sans rien faire donc c'est un
pari risqué que fait aimer l macron et
puis on voit bien que dans ces
régionales toute cette stratégie
finalement nationale se met en jeu c'est
le le jeu dans les hauts de france avec
eric dupond moretti en espagne et une
hache et gérald darmanin qui sont tous
sur une liste contre d'allier bertrand
qui pourrait être ce candidat qui
viendraient un peu joué un chien dans un
jeu de quilles et empêcher emmanuel
macron d'être le candidat de centre
droit social démocrate parce que on voit
que lui monte dans les sondages c'est un
candidat déclaré à droite donc c'est un
jeu auquel jouer les mamans depuis
maintenant plus d'un an et on voit aussi
d'ailleurs qu'il essaye de parler au
delà de sa base vers des publics plus
segmentée c'est le cas de la vidéo sur
youtube avec max icarly tôt pour le veau
john mais aussi il est beaucoup sur tik
tok par exemple où il répond à des
segments de deux français donc on voit
qu'il a une approche très marketing du
vote très loin d'un programme très loin
d'un bilan qu'il pourrait défendre il
est là en train de se vendre comme un
produit marketing et c'est ce qu'il a
fait d'ailleurs en 2017
il refait ce coup là en 2022 est ce que
ça peut marcher on le verra tous les
candidats ne sont pas déclarés et comme
je le disais on est à un an de la
présidentielle et a beaucoup moins de
temps maintenant d'air
régionales qui approchent à grand pas
qui sont les siens un enjeu national
pour l'elysée qui semble déjà avoir fait
une croix sur l'arène où et quand marche
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression que
c'est un parti déjà mort ou déjà
abandonné 1 par emmanuel macron qui lui
avait pourtant donné ses initiales on
sent bien que ce parti est une étiquette
qu'on n'essaye pas de montrer qu'on
essaie plutôt de cacher dans plutôt un
repoussoir mais c'est un parti utile
parce qu'ils les deux partis de la
majorité assis sur un trésor de guerre
en termes d'argent une argent qui sera
bien nécessaire pour la campagne de 2022
mais emmanuel macron va chercher à
dépasser le cadre de la république en
marche avec une plateforme pour un
renouveau présidentielle avec des micro
partis comme celui par exemple d'edouard
philippe qu'il a créé au havre où le
groupe agir d'autres issus du modem ou
bien des députés démissionnaires de la
république en marche qui vont créer
d'autres groupes pour aller
agrégé une nouvelle majorité
présidentielle d'ailleurs on ne s'y
trompe pas richard ferrand président de
l'assemblée nationale à des jeux de
cette semaine avec edouard philippe le
maire du havre
donc les grandes manoeuvres sont
enclenchées parce qu'il va falloir faire
de la politique politicienne pour
dépasser la république en marche avec
par exemple cette attaque semble pour
les causes qui a été mis en ligne mais
aussi agrégé d'autres partis et ne pas
défendre un bilan finalement bien maigre
1 on se demande quelle va être la
l'eulex des malades mâcon pour défendre
son bilan gestion calamiteuse du coc
vide l'emploi qui ne va pas plaire les
façons ce qui ne va pas très bien avec
les choix qui ont été faits dans cette
gestion de crise mais aussi là où il
devait être le grand réformateur des
réformes qui n'arrivent pas à terme
comme celle des retraites l'assurance
chômage critiqué par tous les
partenaires sociaux sur le volet social
et bien simplement divisé les classes de
cp en deux c'est assez faible
le pass culture assez faible aussi donc
ça risque d'être compliqué et ces
régionales sont un laboratoire avec
l'idée justement de ne pas présenter ce
vraiment de candidats d'un public en
marche comme une chance de gagner ils
ont certes des sièges n'est pas de
vainqueur sans doute donc de les ancrer
quand même dans les régions parce que
aux municipales ça n'a pas fonctionné
avec typiquement en paca ce qu'il s'est
passé avec renaud muselier de faire un
peu le coucou
un de listes existantes que ce soit l
air ou ou d'autres partis qui
accepteront d'avoir des députés de la
république en marche à leurs côtés et ça
c'est très ancien monde 1 typiquement le
parachutage daniel spagnou d'acheter
dans notre france tient poser question
puisque dans son cabinet travaille son
son concubin elle s'en est expliqué au
micro d'une radio nationale en disant
que tout était en règle mais ça pose
quand même beaucoup de questions sur la
façon dont sont gérés encore une fois
ces candidatures et on en parle
peut-être un peu moins les foules 1 et
la gauche dans ton ça oui c'est vrai
qu'on en parle de la gauche mais
uniquement pour ses affaires un contrat
familial j'ai envie de dire où on voit
que l'union de la gauche est en train de
s'amenuiser de partir loin vers
l'horizon
on attaque côté jean luc mélenchon 1 qui
choisi de tracer sa route en regardant
de loin cette hypothétique nom de la
gauche qui ressemble fort à un accord de
partie entre eux élevé le ps le pcf sans
doute pour les législatives et au delà
et on voit bien que même chez eux élevé
on se pose beaucoup de questions non
avec un yannick jadot qui aimeraient
enjamber la primaire du parti pour être
le candidat désigné d'office faire un
accord immédiat avec anne hidalgo
hidalgo elle aussi bien gênés 1 par la
candidature d'audrey pulvar en région
parisienne elle est obligée de la
soutenir bien sûr c'est la candidat ps
mais elle a pris ses distances
ll empêtré dans la gestion de la ville
de paris donc on voit bien que la gauche
est totalement à contre-courant
finalement des préoccupations des
français uniquement occupé très occupé
par ses affaires d'union ses affaires
familiales sa survie tout simplement
parce que c'est ce qui se joue pour le
parti socialiste en l'occurrence olivier
faure 1 qui a dit tout et son contraire
la semaine dernière qui a bien du mal à
expliquer la ligne du parti socialiste
donc vraiment à gauche on ne les voit
pas en ordre de bataille
sauf pour jean luc mélenchon qui a
choisi lui de se lancer très tôt en
campagne avec une plate forme
programmatique et déjà beaucoup de
meetings prévus mais on est loin encore
du conte et de l'union de la gauche
donc on voit bien que en ce moment c'est
vraiment une drôle de campagne qui
s'annonce beaucoup de communication
beaucoup de marketing sans doute un peu
de
grande aussi et on est loin encore de
cette élection présidentielle il y aura
sans doute beaucoup de choses à dire
d'ici là et on ira avec vous notamment
merci alexis poulain